Este martes las autoridades mexicanas
anunciaron que dos de los cuatro
estadounidenses que fueron raptados por
narcotraficantes están muertos mientras
que hay una mujer viva y otro hombre
herido quienes han regresado a Estados
Unidos misma suerte que correrán los
restos de los asesinados en las próximas
horas las razones del caso no están
claras aún y los investigadores
mexicanos creen que se trató de un error
todo parece ser que fue una confusión
Pero eso no lo Irán
concluyendo ya las investigaciones como
conforme vayan avanzando por su parte el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
rechazó la intervención de países
extranjeros en el combate contra los
cárteles esto es un asunto nuestro
y además presidente baile
me ha ofrecido
que van a ser respetuosos de nuestra
soberanía
Y eso pues se agradece porque nosotros
no vamos a permitir
intervencionismos
de ningún país extranjero México no es
Colonia
desde Estados Unidos han destacado la
labor de las autoridades gubernamentales
del país vecino Pero catalogaron como
inaceptable este suceso y dejaron la
puerta abierta para una reacción contra
los cárteles
en términos de justicia y rendición de
cuentas Esto es algo que estará dentro
del alcance de nuestros colegas
encargados de hacer cumplir la ley por
supuesto el FBI está involucrado en esto
las autoridades mexicanas están
involucradas en esto no me corresponde a
mí ni al departamento de estado ser
prescriptivo pero en última instancia
queremos que se rindan cuentas por la
violencia que se ha infligido a estos
estadounidenses que trágicamente
murieron los cuatro ciudadanos
estadounidenses habían viajado a México
para que uno de ellos se sometiera a una
cirugía estética cuando fueron
interceptados y baleados por hombres
armados en un nuevo caso que reflotó la
preocupación estadounidense sobre la
violencia generalizada en suelo mexicano